first of all thank you Greg for the
opportunity to be here what I took this
as was an
opportunity just to riff so I hope you
don't mind the Greg said your first it's
for an audience that is going to be
thinking broadly about digital health
and AI
I'll wait you can get them that's okay
but so take this as high level welcome
anyone to tweet at HMK L feel I say
anything try not to embarrass me
disclosures so one of the issues is you
know this is going to cure everything
we're gonna have everything fixed
because of this I mean medicine is going
to be forever different we we hear this
all the time and the question is how are
we going to bridge between hype often
with little evidence I mean the whole
issue about ther knows by the way just
to introduce ther Knossos where was the
evidence where was the public
transparency where was the validation of
what they did come she was worth nine
billion dollars at one point the company
was going to transform the way in which
medicine was practiced and this is
emblematic of a lot of what's going on
in our field which is there's a lot of
hope a lot of aspiration a lot of
possibility but there's also a lot of
claims and one of our major issues is
going to be to try to bridge this and
you know the notion is that I mean
people talk about artificial
intelligence some the AMA wants to call
it augmented intelligence because they
want to make sure you know it's not
going to replace doctors we're trying to
figure out the technical piece of this
but there's also going to be a very
important cultural part of it which is
you know who's gonna trust these new
systems these new approaches to what
extent are they new approaches anyway
and you know some of our cultural frame
comes from the movies and our literature
in science fiction and I'm sure you all
know this quote I'm sorry Dave I'm
afraid I can't do that you know this
quote so I just try this I don't usually
do this but let's see if this works
Geremi hell hello hell do you read me oh
hell do you read me
do you read me huh affirmative time I
read you open the pod bay doors hell I'm
sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do that
what's the problem I think you know what
the problem is just as well as I do what
are you talking about this mission is
too important for me to allow you to
jeopardize it I don't know what you're
talking about how I know that you and
Frank we're planning to disconnect me
and I'm afraid that's something I cannot
allow to happen
[Music]
where the hell did you get that idea
help although you took very thorough
precautions in the part against my
hearing you
I could see your lips move
[Music]
well you get the idea the cultural idea
about whether AI is actually going to
help us or destroy us is not exactly new
and has been reverberating through a
wide variety of wide variety of genre
and you know including what James
Cameron did around when Skynet becomes
self-aware but even more recently the
issues with the 737 max raised the
question of who's in charge of the plane
into what extent can we depend on these
systems to keep us safe now that being
said the auto pilots in all of the
technology and the artificial
intelligence that exists within the
planes have no doubt saved more lives
than we've lost but it still disturbs a
public who wonders whether or not we can
trust information that's being processed
in this way and I just I know this is
hard to see in the audience but I want
to refer you to an article that came out
in nature just this week called machine
behavior in which there was an outline
of the various different ways in which
we need to think about how AI may be
affecting our lives anything from news
ranking algorithms do the algorithms
create filter bubbles does the algorithm
disproportionately censor content to
algorithmic justice do they discriminate
against a racial group in granting
parole to predict the policing systems
increased false conviction rates people
are using predictive models for this
autonomous vehicles autonomous weapons
algorithmic trading algorithmic pricing
online dating conversational robots the
there are many ways in which our society
the central fabric of it is already
being deeply influenced and in some ways
made vulnerable but also stronger in
many ways by the use of these algorithms
and when as we contemplate its
introduction in integration into
medicine these same kind of questions
will become much more prevalent and will
challenge us to think about what the
right way to use them are I thought this
was really interesting because it these
there are prediction models for parole
and increasingly people are using
algorithms and this is so things are
consequential but it's even becoming
more consequential as papers are
starting to come out and predict your
prognosis and what if they're biased
what if they aren't as accurate what's
the validation how can you trust them
what was included in them these things
are going to have very large
consequences for us as we go on there
are other issues about this revolution
which it has to do with the workflow and
the way in which they're implemented
will they be seamless or will they be
distracting this is the famous painting
this is someone's Moo sort of making
light heartedness of what this painter
might put out today if they were to take
a look at the way in which the workflow
goes for most doctors and again this
isn't a direct harm of the digital
medicine and AI world but it's it's a
side effect of the way in which it's
being implemented in the way in which
it's disturbed the way that we we have
traditionally practice medicine my own
sense of opportunity and about this is
when I see that Amazon learns you know
every purchase on Amazon every search on
Google every mile driven on Tesla makes
these companies smarter they're built to
learn with each interaction they
generate collective knowledge I I often
when I'm trying to make this point say
that you know Amazon doesn't say we need
to be a smarter company so we need a big
R&D division what I'm gonna do is hire a
bunch academics from Yale we're gonna
cut a data set from the last three years
at Amazon of course we don't have data
for the last 18 months because it takes
18 months for the data to come in so
we're gonna give them three years of
data but that starts the most recent
date will be 18 months ago we're gonna
give them a grant we're gonna ask them
to give us some specific aims and really
dive into this data and give us some
insights for our business we'll give
them a three to five year grant yet that
maybe will give them three the last four
to no-cost extensions at least we're
going to the up to five then they'll
come out they'll make a few
presentations of meetings but they won't
really have their papers ready till the
end they'll submit their papers it'll
take them two years to publish those
papers then what we're going to do at
Amazon is we're going to have journal
clubs what we're gonna have some journal
clubs as soon as those papers are
published as soon as those papers are
published we're gonna get around most a
lot of our people around lunches and and
you know we'll bring food and we'll talk
about the papers and we'll talk about
what they showed and then what we're
gonna do is take another year and we'll
write some guidelines at Amazon because
we're going to take those papers and
then we're going to turn them into
standard operating procedures and
policies that will govern the way we do
at Amazon and that's gonna make Amazon
great that's going to make sure we serve
every customer and then we're going to
do it again because we're so happy with
this you know it's true the data is a
decade at old by the time it gets out
and it's so effective to have journal
clubs and guidelines and tell people
what they should do that we're going to
keep doing it again and again again
we're gonna spend tons of money on this
and we're gonna be the best company ever
that that's I don't know if you've
noticed that's not what they do
but they every time you click in Amazon
they get smarter their algorithms
learned they're more customized they're
more personalized they're sharper and
and that doesn't exist at all in
medicine we sequester knowledge we
sequester data we silo it the next
person isn't benefited from all the
people that came before we don't create
collective knowledge we we look for the
pearson with gray hair and try to figure
out the person's had the most experience
and hope that their own cognitive biases
don't conspire against any sort of
wisdom that they may want to provide and
then occasionally we'll write check
textbooks or case studies but it takes a
long time so what is this AI thing
anyway you know to just to get into this
by the way what it is mostly right now
it's a means by which companies can give
valuation and with all respect Walter I
think it's brilliant to name it dot AI
like that must have doubled your
valuation right away so you know and I
think as Greg showed you look at the
digital health side literally if I say
that and I add a word like blockchain in
I'll get another 25% and then if I wave
my hands and say digital medicine on top
you know it all of a sudden I can get a
lot of investors and I know it seems
crazy but that's really I've seen it
time and time again and I'm not even
really sure what it is there do
now the the AI has got a taxonomy
there's a lot of different areas machine
learning natural language processing
expert systems computer vision speech
there's a whole range of different areas
but it's not enough to say that there
are these technical things the truth is
a lot of the big companies like Google
have made it quite easy for even people
with quite standard skills to be playing
in a very sophisticated space tensorflow
has has transformed the way we've done
at microsoft's done the same amazon
they've commoditized to a large extent
that's not to diminish the amazing work
that's being done across campus where
people are doing cutting-edge new
algorithms and solving hard problems but
we haven't even begun to crawl in
medicine I mean we could make use of the
kind of technology and knowledge that
was available decade ago and we'd be way
ahead of where we are now I thought was
interesting when I looked at Google
Trends for AI by the way this goes back
to 2004 as far back as they go and you
know actually it's only in the last
couple years this thing has really taken
off in terms of being sort of a a trend
it's not that they I was ever not there
if you look at citations or paper
production going back to 1950 people
were talking about AI for a long time
but but you're seeing a growing and this
is by the way this is exponential so
you're seeing a growing amount of
material that's being put out there and
you know you may have noticed the Turing
awards this year went to a Benjy lacunae
and Hinton for their work in in neural
nets and that really is the work they
did in the late 90s and early 2000s that
sort of led to what we're able to do
today which has really been
transformative so this is a quote from
an article that's but I thought it was
instructive because it sort of tells you
why now what is really going on now and
it's really that cheap processing power
from GPUs which were originally designed
for gaming you know I talked about CPUs
wherein you're no ordinary computers but
people talk about these GPUs because
they were sort of built for video gaming
they were they were sort of maximizing
the ability to do high level
computations for gaming and an abundance
of digital data
mostly given off by the internet the
same way a car gives off fumes offered
fuels for these little cognitive engines
and since 2012 the basic techniques that
have been Joe Hinton and laocoön
pioneered including back propagation
CNN's have become ubiquitous and for
technology's whole but but I'm telling
you that these guys did such a good job
and that the people in this field are so
generous that actually it has been
commoditized to a large extent at the at
the I wouldn't say the bottom level but
at a very sophisticated level of being
able to do this work and so you know
people talk about artificial
intelligence broadly in machine learning
even logistic regression a traditional
technique we use when we use the
computer to select the variables in the
model is a form of machine learning so
we machine learning is not also a
necessarily new technique but it's this
deep learning that but as often comes
with a black box
it's these techniques that produce
output that can be very close to optimal
solutions and optimize what it is you're
looking at but without telling you
exactly what it is and so these are the
this is a timeline at the bottom and
sort of says you know AI capture the
Intel the imagination of the world
machine learning starts to gain traction
but it's really in the last 10 years and
again with the computation with the
cloud with what the big companies have
produced and with the large amounts of
data increasingly available we've
started to enter a time of deep learning
and and you all are taking advantage of
it I mean anyone who has one of the new
iPhones you know is basically and at
your everyday life is making use of
these algorithm and you're used to
making use of them all the time in so
many different ways that you're not
available to including all those
potentially hazardous ways that are
potentially affecting society but but
just as a simple way I mean this is
enabled because of the work that that
they did and it's it's it's changed this
guy writes in ten years the iPhone
replaced all this stuff that like used
to be in a Radio Shack ad but but a lot
of the stuff that's being done on your
phone today is a result of what is what
is behind it and under the hood in AI
system so you know who doesn't use one
of these to try to figure out what route
to take for a trip I mean it's not
enough that we see a map anymore and to
be able to project it's not just showing
you the traffic but it's projecting what
the traffic is going to be going on
Google Maps and say I want to go to the
airport on what you can put what day at
what time and it's projecting for you
what it's going to be like based on what
it knows
I mean it's changing every facet of our
lives but still remains a little bit
outside of medicine
so what's medicine like you know
medicine still like this you know you
know this old saw from the weather red
sky at night sailor's delight red sky in
the morning sailors take warning have
you ever ever heard that so you know
that's a heuristic you know it's a rule
of thumb it's like okay I know this then
that should probably happen it actually
showed up even back in the Bible in the
New Testament in Matthew he said he
answered them when it's evening you say
it's whether for the sky is red in the
morning today for the sky is red and
threatening English standard version of
the New Testament so I mean this is this
is but by the way this is sort of like
what medicine is now you know I if you
see this that means that and by the way
it's it's not bad I mean what it means
is the sun's coming up and if this if
the clouds are coming from the west
toward the east the sunlight reflects
off moisture-laden underside of the
clouds and produces red that works if
the if the clouds are going from west to
east actually if the clouds are going
from east to west the skies clearing and
it's actually not telling you the same
in and it's certain latitudes in the
country depending on the prevailing
winds that'll either work well or it's
not and that's also a lot like medicine
you know these heuristics sometimes work
sometimes they don't put but it's a
question of whether we need to get to
more sophisticated approaches so what
the National Weather Service didn't
start accumulating a lot of these
heuristics but instead they did started
collecting a lot of data and I think
what's going on in the Weather Service
is a good example to us you know there
are millions of sensors then they
collect data all over the world and
those that data is streamed into
supercomputers where they have the most
advanced algorithms in which they're
trying to make predictions so that I can
tell not only what's going to happen
today but 10 days I know people like to
make fun of weather
four casters but I find they're mostly
accurate there it's remarkable and it is
very different than what I remember
growing up I mean they are pretty good
and and not only that they do a really
good job of taking complicated
information and showing it in ways that
are easy to understand that this isn't
maybe even the best example but my
mother lives in Florida you know and the
way she never took the course she never
got the degree in weather maps but you
know she's watching the TV she's seen a
weather map and she's saying to me you
know well that hurricane that's coming
you know the European model looks like
it may go a little north of us and the
American model looks like it could come
to us and there's a lot of uncertainty
it could either come to us she's talking
about confidence intervals and different
models and like it's amazing I mean you
know you can actually take this very
complex information and portray it in
ways that are easy to understand and
this is today's map and it's got high
dimensional information it's got it
tells you location it tells you type of
precipitation the intensity the
precipitation and this is a very simple
map but underneath it underneath it is
very deep math and very deep data and
you know this is what the promise in
medicine I think is you know same with
these autonomous vehicles I think what's
interesting about them is they're not
being taught to drive individually but
they're being prepared to be able to
communicate with each other in a
collective and not only that unlike
medicine it's not like one car learns
and then by the way by the car that's
really smart like that's a good car to
get like which one of these is a
smartest car it's like every mile that
was ever driven makes the next car
smarter and better able to work and it's
working collaboratively with all the
other cars eventually if we get into
this kind of ecosystem and again
different from medicine where like I may
be smart I may have a lot of experience
I may have done I got to find a smart
doctor who the best doctors you know
it's insane really if you think about it
that that it's like that so the the
opportunity that exists within medicine
is this digitization of the data you
know the crash in 2008 led to a large
investment in making most of the medical
information in the country digital so
that means
Edison could play in this field I mean
what was essential for all of these
things was that there be data and you
know we have tons of data sources both
in the clinical arena but also in
people's lives that that are relevant to
healthcare decisions and to speak to the
empowerment choices that they have to
make and understanding what trade-offs
are of different decisions and so that
this is the we've just gone through just
about a decade of getting to the point
where so much health information
particularly in the clinical arena is
now digital and the possibility of
connecting people in learning and
creating a collective wisdom not a
sequestered knowledge where you're
finding the smartest doctor but the
means by which every person who comes
through is generating insights that's
leading to a collective stronger whole
that that's the Holy Grail that's what
we need to be going for but meanwhile
the experience is very different you
know this is an article Gandhi writes
why doctors hate their computers doctors
instead of being so excited about this
era thinking that wow I'm it's like
giving me a jetpack instead of walking
places I'm gonna get places fast or
quicker I'm gonna be going in the air
it's gonna be so much fun to do my job
now doctors think this is just crushing
them and you know Gandhi said I've come
to feel a system that promised to
increase my mastery over my work is
instead increased my works mastery over
me know that you want to listen to
negative response from doctors tell them
you've got a technology solution for
something tell them you're gonna help
them in their everyday work by adding
decision support for example to the EHR
like look at the expression on their
face when you start telling them how
you're here to help it's not well
received in and for good reason so far
the experience of most practitioners has
been negative and for most patients has
been neutral it's been in or negative in
the sense that it's pulling people's
eyes away from them the connection the
the all this empowerment has yet to be
achieved meanwhile like what's happening
in the nation we digitized since 2008 we
are gaining greater capability we think
the day is gonna help so much
but like you see this is life expectancy
at birth on the
y-axis health expenditure at the bottom
everyone else is spending a lot less and
getting a lot more life expectancy we're
spending so much more and it hasn't
changed at all since since the
institution of all this digital data
we're off the curve and we remain off
the curve we're getting more and more
off the curve all the time for other
countries the more you spend on health
the longer you get for life expectancy
of course that's not just health care
that's economic well-being that's that's
a lot of things that go with that
but you know it starts to flatten out at
a point but the u.s. is way off the
curve and there's no sign that we're
getting closer to the curve so far with
what we've been able to implement and if
anything our life expectancies you may
have seen from the CDC is actually
dropping now you can say suicide opioids
despair that's not a ice fault okay
some but society culture our health care
our ability to focus on well-being all
these things are connected to this and
we at least can say we're not making it
a lot better since we've gone through
this so so what are the what is it that
makes you optimist again I will say I
grow too my disclosure my last one was
I'm an optimist
I actually think of the next decade
medicine will be fundamentally different
believe healthcare be fundamentally
different in our ability to promote
health will be fundamentally different
and better and remarkably better and it
will forge new models of the way in
which this will work but but how is this
gonna go from a paper culture and even
though we are digital we trust me it is
mostly a paper culture in this
retrofitting of a digital world into
paper workflows instead of rethinking
the entire way the system is set up what
individual patients need who needs to
see them at what level what can be
handled at home or by you know other
means and making people wait in a
waiting room and see one by one for a
ten minute talk in which eight minutes
are spent trying to find the data that's
necessary for the meeting how many times
have i sat with a patient where they had
to dump all their pills on the desk and
we spent most of the meeting just trying
to figure out what's in the bottles like
that that's the current state even today
and then we still arrive with human
error human ears everywhere in our
system
there's estimate between this is an old
estimate forty-four and ninety-six
thousand people dying US hospitals
result of human error people call it the
third leading cause of death the we've
got an imperative to start thinking
about how do we use data these smart
systems to make it a safer more
effective more equitable system it's
it's there in front of us but but you
know the opportunities to grow is
immense this is the state of the art
right now for helping a patient make a
decision about whether they should thin
their blood if they've got a heart
rhythm problem called atrial
fibrillation they've got an irregular
heart rate which can cause a stroke we
we often will suggest that they take a
blood thinner in order to reduce the
risk but that incurs a risk of bleeding
so it can be a tough decision but what
we do is we've created this risk or
that's not more than your hands and
fingers and I said it because if we have
Armageddon and there's no electricity
you can still do it because you just use
your hands and it's one point or two
points really easy if you have
hypertension no matter what kind of
hypertension you get a point if you get
a heart failure if it's severe or it's
no I you had a twenty years ago or it's
how yesterday we'll give you a point if
you're a woman we give you a point no
matter what kind of woman you are
so you know it does and then we have a
heuristic if you have two points you
should be anticoagulated that's what a
lot of that's what our guidelines say I
mean it does this is this is the how far
we have to go in an era where you're at
using a sophisticated AI and massive
computers to tell you how what route to
take home and yet when you have a
decision about whether you should take a
blood thinner or not instead of giving
you a precise estimate for bleeding and
for stroke what the likely gain is who
what you are trading off in the decision
none of that in the current era is
available so my point is to try to push
this idea to learn from every
interaction built from collective wisdom
my my friend Eric Topol wrote this book
about trying to talk mostly inspire
people the possibilities and the way the
humanity can be put back into this
somebody tell Eric I did this so that
he'll be happy but you know it's an idea
where he's collecting stories and giving
examples and so it's starting to gain
some traction
this is you know Google's done a lot of
work with looking at the fundus and they
say here in their ad I thought was cute
the same technology that knows your dog
from a cat helped doctors know healthy
eye from an at-risk one but yet still
nobody's using it in practice in at
scale right now so will they spread how
will it spread for individuals I don't
even need to see a doctor I may be able
to take a picture of my eye and get some
sort diagnosis people are doing that for
rashes now I mean the possibilities of
people being able to have pattern
recognition without needing to go find a
doctor or many doctors may not be
experienced in this or skilled or since
medical school may not have had much
practice and for a rare rash or unusual
findings in the retina but but a AI
system could do it remarkably well this
is something that happened this week
just to give you a sense of the breadth
of possibility you may have heard this
brain signals transfer translated into
speech using artificial intelligence so
they had a bunch of meet with epilepsy
who are already getting a patch placed
on the brain to collect information and
what they did was they had these people
read and then they use that as the
training set and then they had a bunch
of people then read to themselves and
try see if they knew what what it would
do to muscles and they tried to create
speech out of it so people are just
thinking words there are many people who
are paralyzed and can't speak and so or
or intubated or a wide range of things
where they can't communicate and this
was the patch that was on the brain but
take a listen to this so the first thing
is going to be the person reading the
second is what they're thinking in what
the computer is able to produce
Shipbuilding is a most fascinating
process she feel even in Western as a
unique process the proof that you are
seeking is not available in books the
provincial are seeking is sign the
livonian moves so the point is not
perfect but they're early and that's a
remarkable replication of what it is
that someone's saying and I think sort
of amazing so you know what
gonna keep us from getting to where we
need to go I mean we need to be able to
get the data to produce the knowledge to
get the action we've got to be thinking
clearly about you know what are the
right problems to focus this on by the
way using AI to tell me something I
already know something that's obvious
something that's that I you know doesn't
necessarily require is if anything
wasteful if not insulting I mean we need
to be able to figure out where's the
where's the place to focus and we also
going to need to be thinking about like
the meteorologists how do we communicate
information so under the hood it's
really hardcore math there on under the
hood its high-level computation but
where it gets to the people who are
using it we've understand their task
we've understand their information needs
we've understand how they can perceive
and so like my mother you never have to
take a class in weather you don't have
to become a meteorologist or like the
iPhone I mean you know my mother's 80
being filmed so I won't say my mother's
older than I am
and she is able to use a lot of the
technology seamlessly because of the way
that the design was now every day
someone's pushing something this just
came out this week was approved by the
FDA for chronically ill people it uses
machine learning to by the way cleared
not approved it's clear so that means
that they didn't make an assessment of
whether or not it it does something
beneficial they said you know it's it
fits with predicate devices that would
say it can collect information and show
but they say it uses machine learning to
analyze data collects and notifies
doctors and problematic changes on their
mobile devices or in electronic health
records
now I didn't spend hours but I'd spent
some time trying to figure out where's
the data where's the paper what exactly
have they done and I can't find it now
it may be out there but the question is
where will this be catalogued what
independent group is going to be looking
at the work that people do to give some
sense of what it produces I will say
that in the end my own sense of this is
that it's going to be really important
for us to get data the major choke point
for most of what we want to do in
medicine still remains
the absence of training sets the absence
of the data that we need and even though
we can declare victory on so much of the
data being digitized it still is not
well integrated we have interoperability
issues it's siloed Laocoon says he's
optimistic about the prospects of
artificial intelligence but he's also
clear that much more work needs to be
done before the field lives up to its
promise korean AI system needs lots of
data to understand the world can be
easily tricked and we're only good at
specific tasks we just don't have
machines with common sense I want to
just unpack this a second he does say
lots of data first and I think it's a
requirement how are we going to break
down the barriers so that we can
actually get the data we need to do the
work he does say by the way easily trick
that gets to the bias issue that I
mentioned and then we're only good at
specific tasks I do want to say that
there are a lot of tasks that people say
AI for because it sounds cool but
actually doesn't perform any better than
more traditional ways of doing things so
we always ought to be defaulting to
simpler is better and I think this is
wise but you know this is the famous
Sherlock Holmes quote day to day to data
I can't make bricks without clay you can
have the most sophisticated approaches
but if we don't have the reagents that
we need it's not going to work we all
have been working very hard to try to
not be under the thumb of the electronic
health care vendor but to be able to
create our own integrated data
repository that can stream and integrate
data from all parts of the healthcare
system whether they're coming from
machines or from directly from patients
or whether they're in the in the
clinical record so that we can control
our destiny about the data then we get
it into a place where we can harmonize
it and organize it and create common
data models so we can collaborate with
others and we believe that this is going
to be the way of the future all of the
places that have hold data need to not
be trapped by proprietary models but be
in a position where they're using
open-source tools so they can avidly set
the rules for those who want to work
with them and they can also make it so
that every new decision support or every
new tool that someone wants to say
doesn't require a different way in that
there's a standard way in which everyone
interacts with the system and we can
learn so we're building platforms for
real-time clinical and
trying to see if we can achieve this
idea of data coming in and learning and
being able to then send it back at the
point-of-care and doing it so fast that
it's occurring in a time frame that can
be helpful this changing consumer data
revolution is also important piece that
greg said and I personally am highly
committed to this and have developed and
founded a company that is intended to
try to help people be empowered with
their data the notion being no data
should be sold behind your back you
should be able to get agency over your
data that data should be able to be
integrated and acquired seamlessly and
should be prepared for your use
clinical use for you to participate in
research for wide variety of purposes
and so this is just one I'm not just
saying that this is what we've done
enables people collect a broad range of
health data people can get it from their
records from their wearables from CVS
from from Medicare from from wherever it
sits and fill out surveys and they can
build their own health data assets so
then they can participate in a health
data environment and echo system and
also be able to make sure that their
experience feeds into the knowledge of
helping the next person who's going to
follow them and you know we're deeply
committed to this idea of paying it
forward and when you talk to most
patients they said I want the next
person to be in a better position than I
was I want the knowledge to not have
been lost as a result we also been
realized that the challenge is not only
acquiring and normalizing the data but
ensuring high quality data harmonization
bringing together data from different
sources and ensuring we know the meaning
of each element data quality is not a
commodity it's a point of
differentiation what I learned was that
all of these vendors they created
dialects they may have had the same
products but the Hartford hospitals epic
is very different from Yale's epic and
you've got to then be able to create the
engines that create the semantic
interoperability and the means by which
we can line up and map the information
and meaningful ways that that shouldn't
have been necessary but it turns out to
be an important other obstacle for one
of our patients you know it's going to
enable us to collect dense data about
things that we just didn't have any idea
about this is a patient who the the
right at the zero of the x-axis is
pre-op and then they had mitral valve
repair and we started
a whole range of questions on them and
about their activity and their sleep
this is at just activities of daily
living to start to chart their recovery
after surgery before this you would ask
the surgeon well how long is it gonna be
before I feel better I don't know they
say I don't know maybe a month maybe two
months I don't know you know we don't we
weren't charting this experience we
weren't being able to say well who will
recovers the best who the worst
by the way when we're looking at you and
you come into the office are you at the
50th percentile are you at the top at
the bottom
can we preempt problems because we tell
you're not making it like we would do
with growth curves and children hey
you're falling off the recovery curve
maybe there's something we need to do to
intervene the the promise of digital
medicine now is that this stuff can move
quickly seamlessly it's timely the
marginal cost is low we can get people
on board and at most people already have
mobile devices so it's not like I have
to stock everyone with their own
personal computers they've actually most
people have it in its growing over time
so it's a remarkable opportunity so just
to finish up I say you know 1903 the the
Wright brothers are Kitty Hawk I mean
they're happy they're going a football
field or two you know and celebrating
that they can just even get this thing
to to seemingly make any movement at all
and you know like a decade later for
unfortunate purposes but by decade later
we've got planes flying all over the
place in World War one you know that the
investment the commitment yeah was about
a war but but it meant that that just
think about that 1903 you know that's
the first time they're getting getting
off the ground and in decade later this
becomes almost routine and then you know
to the point we are today so the
opportunity I think is of this digital
medicines to leverage the digital
transformation to learn from every
interaction to create tools for people
and I'd say that first for people and
then for health professionals health
systems and policy makers that elevate
performance improve outcomes drive value
and ultimately promote health and
well-being in ways that we've been able
to work inform choices in ways we
haven't been able to do before
help people learn from each other and
figure out what they want to do in the
end I just want to say while we talk
about all this technology it
to serve the people and need people who
depend on this information to be right
the people who are looking up in moments
where they're most vulnerable and
weakest and hoping that the systems are
there to protect them promote promote
their interest and make sure the best
things happen so with that I want to say
thank you maybe just a few minutes for
questions now so what are the three most
important things data data data
so let's if there's a in the spirit of
the symposium very thought-provoking
let's leave time for a question or two
if anybody has a comment or question we
have mics down front if you can good
morning thank you for an excellent
presentation my question is not about
data but the algorithms that go with it
and primarily regulating those
algorithms Mison the example you showed
I studied remember studying that back in
the 80s as an undergrad it explained
itself and it did it quite fairly well
my scenario almost in certain cases
almost 60% accuracy but it explained
itself but today we have algorithms that
are proprietary intellectual property so
how would be regulated should we have
clinical trials for algorithms or should
it be should I explain itself should it
be open source I think it's really good
question how do we evaluate these and I
think we have to realize that there are
several aspects to any of this they are
complex interventions so there's a
question of whether they do what you
expect it's sort of like does this pill
do what I expect it to do and then when
I use this pill under ideal conditions
does it produce what I hope it will for
human health and then when it's in the
real world outside of that idealized
environment does it produce what I hope
it can do it and it can fail at each
step it can fail in its mechanism it can
fail in it under ideal conditions it can
fail because everything was perfect but
when it's being used by people in the
real world
it's used in ways that that counter
veena I mean even like 737 max you could
have said well if you had a pilot who
really knew how to manage that plane in
that moment they would have averted the
crash but an average pilots not ready
within 30 seconds to be able to spring
to action on that even if one time they
heard an instructional video about it so
I think that we there we need to be
thinking about those three levels like
we do for pills but I also then think we
need to think about what's at stake so
high stake decisions high stake issues
should play I think we need to be able
to invest more and understanding what
what it's doing and the interpretability
of it is more important we can't just
have a black box and assume it's working
because one day someone validated it if
it's continuing to evolve we need
interpretability we need to continue
testing if this thing is telling who can
go on parole if it's saying who can die
and people are making decisions on life
extending therapy as a result we need to
be able if it's flying planes we need to
be trying it needs to have a certain
level if it's something like do I want
to buy these socks or those socks
probably it's a very different you know
level of scrutiny that it needs to
undergo because if it's failing then
people just stop buying socks and you
can say we weren't this thing's not
offering people what they want
so I don't have the Pat answer for this
but this is where we are in the field
right we've got to move quickly because
people are promoting solutions where the
data is not transparent and we're not
clear what the validation has been and
and for high stakes decisions it needs
to be absolutely transparent not and
people talk about this a lot Xai the
explainable part the interpretive apart
how do we understand what it is it's
actually producing it we may not really
know within the in the neuro net but we
need to know at least what information
isn't leveraging the most in order to
make the make the output and how are we
continually evaluating whether it's that
and I just say one quick thing and the
bias is going to be really important
just because we can replicate what's
doing if we're getting that result
because we're treating some people in
ways that aren't equitable that we're
not getting we're not treating them well
we don't want to just incorporate that
into an algorithm we
want to actually identify it and get rid
of it so you know these are all
important aspects I think of how this
gets played out
[Applause]